la información que llega desde el centro
de backmud por algunas de las tropas que
todavía permanecen o han estado en las
últimas horas adentro es que los
ucranianos siguen peleando al menos por
esa parte central de la ciudad de
backmud Aunque reconocen que en los
últimos días y especialmente ayer hubo
mayor incursión de las tropas rusas que
atacaron sin parar esa parte de la
ciudad hoy el creador de las fuerzas
wagners
pregosín que es el que ha estado
liderando esta batalla por macbook desde
el pasado verano aseguraba que la ciudad
estaba prácticamente sitiada y que
solamente había una carretera de acceso
como hemos venido comprobando en estos
días que hemos estado en la región sin
embargo lo que dicen las autoridades
ucranianas en estos últimos días tiene
que ver un poco con el que seguirán
luchando por la ciudad incluso la
viceministra de defensa habló de mandar
refuerzos a esta región como vimos ayer
en la carretera que salía de esta región
del Don vas veíamos muchísimas tropas
carros camiones tanques que iban en esa
dirección aunque también veíamos otras
tropas que iban saliendo como Si
estuvieran haciendo intercambio para que
estos pudieran descansar son tropas que
llevan peleando durante semanas y están
bastante agotadas pero también el
portavoz de las fuerzas del más ha dicho
que en el momento que fuera necesario
Ucrania también se retiraría de estas
posiciones de lo que han hablado muchos
de los soldados que han estado allí en
estos últimos días que hablan de esa
posibilidad de retroceder crear
posiciones de defensa y hablar de un
posible ataque en un futuro Ellos dicen
que realmente Esto no es una victoria
para Rusia que lleva peleando siete
meses con todas sus fuerzas allí sino
que hay que recordar que los ucranianos
han podido recuperar regiones como el o
la ciudad de gersón y que esto les
permitirá de cierta manera si logra caer
Back en poder de las fuerzas rusas es
reafirmar estas defensas y volver a
lanzar ataques como ellos esperan esta
Primavera